[MUSIC PLAYING]
VAN RIPER: Hi.
This is Van Riper, the program
manager here at Google for our
Google Developer Groups
worldwide.
For those of you that don't
know, we have more than 400
groups in over 100 countries to
date, holding meetings on
average of upwards of
five meetings a day.
These segments are meant to
share information with those
groups and their organizers.
But it's also for the
general public.
So welcome any of you that
aren't currently members of
our Google Developer
groups communities.
But I hope you'll find
a community in
your area and join.
Today, I'm very happy to have
Bartholomew Furrow and Igor
Naverniouk with me from
the Code Jam team.
Two of the engineers.
We're going to talk to them a
little bit about how they got
involved with Code Jam, the
history of Code Jam, and
answer some of your questions
from the Moderator.
So with that, I'd like to turn
it over to Bart and Igor.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW:
Thank you, Van.
I'm Bartholomew Furrow.
This is Igor Naverniouk.
And I've been a software
engineer at Google for around
six years now.
And before I came to
Google, I got a
couple degrees in physics.
I have a Bachelors of Science
and Physics at Queens
University and a Masters of
Science and Physics at
University of British
Columbia.
And the way I ended up down at
Google is through competitive
programming.
There are a lot of different
programming contests like
Google Code Jam.
And it's through getting
involved in contests like
that, that I built my
programming skills and ended
up working here at Google.
I got involved in programming
contests in 2003, I suppose,
when I was doing my
bachelor's degree.
I just saw a sign one day that
said there's a programming
contest on Saturday in
the math building.
And because I'm the kind
of guy who likes doing
programming contests on
Saturdays in math buildings, I
thought, why not?
And from there, I sort of
parlayed my way onto my
school's ACM team.
We'll talk a bit about that--
it's a different contest--
in a bit.
And then started getting better
at these contests, and
competed in the first
Google Code Jam.
And so after a long road of
contests and competing, I made
my way here.
And now that I'm at
Google, I work on
the ads quality system.
So we're the folks who if you
do a search on google.com,
sometimes you'll see ads above,
or to the right, or
below the search results.
We try to make them great.
And I also have what's called
the 20% Project.
20% Project is when Google
engineers spend a fifth of
their time working on a pet
project, or passion project.
And for me, that's Google Code
Jam, which is what we're here
to talk about today.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: OK.
I'm Igor.
So my history is I was doing
computer science and math
undergrad at the University
of British Columbia.
Back in 2001, I saw a poster
that said, "free pizza and a
programming competition." So
both those things, I thought,
were interesting.
So I showed up.
And that's how I started on this
whole path of programming
competitions.
That was a poster for the ACM
programming competition, which
is a team event for university
students.
And since 2001, I
never stopped.
I've been competing
in programming
competitions for a while.
And then I started
coaching a team.
And then now, I'm working
on Code Jam.
So in 2006, I did
an internship at
Google in the summer.
I thought that was
pretty cool.
So the way I got into that is I
actually did pretty well in
the Code Jam competition that
Google ran that was--
back then, it wasn't run
by Google, itself.
It was sponsored by Google and
ran by a different company.
And in 2007, I came back
for another internship.
Bartholomew was my host.
And the project then was to
build a platform for Code Jam
at Google in house so that
we can do it our way.
So I worked on that.
And since then, joined Google
full time and started working
on Code Jam as my 20% Project,
similar to Bartholomew.
My main project is Android.
I work on all kinds of user
analytics in Android and
Google Play.
And I spent some of my time,
between 5% and 50% sometimes,
on Code Jam.
So that's my story.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: And so for
people who don't know a lot
about competitive programming
or Code Jam, in particular,
let's just sort of give you
a brief introduction.
So for Google Code Jam, this
isn't a hack-a-thon.
What we're doing is we're
going to pose a bunch of
puzzles to you.
We pose between three and five
programming problems,
depending on the contest.
And generally speaking, they're
problems where there's
some sort of a puzzle that
you're trying to solve.
So to give you an example, you
can imagine that you have a
chest board.
And you want to put a bunch of
queens on the chest board so
that none of the queens
can attack each other.
Some of you might have seen that
problem when you were in
high school.
I remember seeing that in
high school and trying
to solve it by hand.
But we could say because we have
computers instead of an
eight by eight chess board with
eight queens, we could do
an n by n chessboard
with n queens.
And we could ask you to write a
program that given n, prints
out good locations for
all of the queens.
So that's just one example
of the sort of problems
that we might ask.
And so a Code Jam round
generally lasts a couple of
hours, asks you a few of these
questions, and whoever can get
the most points off of solving
our problems is the
winner of the round.
And in the Code Jam competition,
we start off with
the qualification round.
Have a few more online rounds
where we gradually reduce the
number of people competing.
And this year we
have are onsite
finals in London, England.
So the top 25 in the world
will be flying
to London to compete.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: So how is Code
Jam different from other
programming competitions?
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW:
Well, it's better.
Code Jam is--
well, I'd say that it's
probably the biggest
algorithmic programming
competition in the world.
So you go up against a lot of
people, including some of the
very best in the world.
We work really hard to get our
problems as great as possible.
I'm sure everybody
else does, too.
But I think we do a particularly
good job.
And you can compete in any
programming language you like.
So if you're a Ruby wizard or
particularly good at PHP,
you're not just stuck with C++
and Java, which some of the
other contests make you be.
You can use any language
you like.
It could be something that
you wrote at home.
And you're your own compiler,
and you want to prove that
your language really works.
And this is a great
place for that.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Yeah, we've
had people compete in some
really weird programming
languages.
There's one guy who's kind of
infamous for trying to solve
every problem in a different
language.
And he keeps choosing more
and more obscure
languages over the years.
Some of the ones with
funny names that I
shouldn't be saying.
[LAUGHTER]
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: Well, last
year he used Shakespeare,
where you write what looks like
a Shakespearean play.
But you write it carefully, and
it turns out to be code.
And he actually solved the
problem using that, which I
was impressed by.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: I think he's
done LOLCODE as well.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: He's
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: So why should
you care about Code Jam?
So first of all, it's fun.
Second of all, I can say,
personally, I've learned a lot
of things from programming
competitions.
Probably more practical things
than I would have learned in
classical studies in
computer science.
The cool thing about programming
competitions, in
general, is that you get our
self-contained problem and you
have to solve it, and you have
to be sure that you solved it.
It's one thing to say, yeah,
I know how to solve that.
But it's another thing to just
sit down, write code that
passes unit test.
There's a big gap between
those two.
And programming competitions
really make you prove it.
Prove that you actually know
how to solve the problem.
Because if you solved 99 out of
100 cases, and you have a
bug somewhere, that's wrong.
We give you no points for that,
which is a little harsh.
And some people find that kind
of not very appealing.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW:
Demoralizing.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Demoralizing.
Yeah, it's a good point.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: But we want
to make sure that you
solve the problem
exactly right.
And so this is a great way
to build strength as a
programmer.
I'd like to think that it builds
up your vocabulary.
Once you can solve more problems
with more and more
ease, then suddenly the things
that you come across at work--
if tomorrow, I came across
at work an nCUBE dynamic
programming algorithm,
I would just do it.
I wouldn't think that that was a
particularly difficult thing
to come across.
Whereas before programming
competitions, that would have
been, well, maybe I can find an
approximation or a quicker
way around it.
But now, you just--
it's just an nCUBE dynamic
programming problem.
You just solve it.
So I think it builds your
ability to work from day to
day, particularly if you use
in Code Jam the programming
language that you use at work.
And another thing is that
it's really good for job
interviews.
For people who interview in
technical interviews, you will
often get asked a question
of the sort that
we ask in Code Jam.
Solve this self-contained,
simple problem, and then write
code for it.
And if you have been competing
in Code Jam or other contests,
then you're an expert at that.
Then you really know
how to do that.
And you go into an interview
and you can blow away those
algorithmic questions.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Yep.
So on interviews, that's
a really good point.
There are some questions--
so I interview a lot of
people at Google.
I think a lot of engineers
do that.
And there are some
questions that
sometimes I ask a candidate.
And candidates who have done
programming competitions
before really get
it immediately.
And others struggle.
Like, for example, I ask
a programming problem.
And I like people
to write code.
And then I ask, how do
you test this code?
So some people with general
programming experience can get
that right.
But then the next question is,
so how big of an input can
this code handle?
And that usually really
puzzles people.
They say, well, I know
this is linear time.
So--
and then they don't know
what to say next.
But somebody with programming
contest experience can
immediately say, OK, so this
is an algorithm that, let's
say, finds blobs and images
or something.
And if you have this experience,
you can say, OK,
on images of say 1,000 by
1,000, this will work.
On a million by a million, this
will definitely not work.
This is really useful in
day-to-day life, as well.
So if you're writing a piece
of code, you have to have a
really good understanding of
what kinds of inputs it can
handle and what kinds of
situations it applies to.
So it means understanding a
full stack from high level
concepts in programming
languages to really down at
the level of machine code.
How fast is this thing
actually running?
And programming competitions
make you understand that whole
range because otherwise, it's
really easy to write some
code, and then try to solve a
problem and find out that it's
just going to run forever.
So that's one of the examples.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: It give
you a lot of practice
in that sort of--
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: It also gives
you a lot of confidence that
you actually get these
things right.
Because you may have an
idea that OK, maybe
this is fast algorithm.
This is not a very
fast algorithm.
But if you can put concrete
numbers on it, it gives you a
lot of confidence to say,
yeah, I actually
know how to do this.
If you give me this problem,
I can go and solve this.
And I don't just tell
you how to solve it.
I actually write code, and
we can test it out.
So it makes things go a lot
faster and smoother in
day-to-day work.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: For sure.
VAN RIPER: So would you like to
take a few of the questions
from the moderator now?
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Sure.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: That's
a great idea.
I'll read out this first one.
So why do you think some
countries, like Russia, Japan,
Poland, and China,
have more top
competitors than other countries?
This also happens in other
contests like the ACM
International Collegiate
Programming Contest.
What's missing from
other countries?
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: I wouldn't say
there's something missing
from other countries.
I think there are some things
that these countries do well.
So I can speak about
Russia because I
know a bit about that.
So the general education system
focuses a lot on math
and science and precise
disciplines like that, a lot
more so than schools
in Canada or United
States focus on that.
That's not necessarily a good
thing or correct way to do
things, but it's definitely
helping people get better at
programming competitions
and math competitions.
Competitions, in general.
Sort of the spirit of
competition is nourished and
encouraged.
We had lots of different
internal competitions in
school back in Russia.
So I think that's one thing that
they do differently, not
necessarily better.
But it helps people get better
programming [INAUDIBLE].
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: It works
for programming contests.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Yes.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: And they
also take these things very
seriously at the university
level.
The ACM-ICPC is this
team event.
And teams represent
universities.
And so some universities take
it seriously enough that, I
think, in some of the Chinese
universities, if you join the
programing team, that's worth
two credits for the semester.
So instead of taking two
classes, you take the
Preparing for Programming
Contest class.
And I don't think that's the
case in very many, or maybe
even any, universities
in North America.
So I think that maybe the
overall summary would be that
in general, schools take
programming contests very
seriously, or much more
seriously, in these countries
than they do in Canada and
the United States.
And I think the schools here
don't really pay a whole lot
of attention.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: There's another
thing I could say
about that.
So the questioner interestingly
mentions Russia,
Japan, Poland, and China.
And if you know some history of
programming competitions,
Japan is actually very
new on that list.
If you look back maybe five
years, it would have been
Russia, Poland, and China.
Japan was nowhere near the top
of any scoreboard of any major
programming competition.
But then something changed.
And I'm not sure exactly
what it is.
But I think what this
says is that
community has a huge effect.
So once you have a few
superstars from a country do
really well in competitions,
then they start growing this
community of other competitors
around them.
And I've seen this happen in
universities, and I've seen
this happen in whole
countries.
So Japan is a great example.
And now Japanese contestants do
extremely well in Code Jam
and TopCoder and other
programming competitions.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW:
That's right.
We had, if I'm not remembering
correctly, in 2011, we had our
world finals for Code Jam
in Tokyo, and a Japanese
competitor won the contest,
which was a first for us, but
I imagine not a last.
So the next question is, how
much do you think cognitive
skills affect someone's
peak performance?
Are people's capacity and
competitive programming
limited to their natural or
genetic intelligence, or can
they get better training?
For example, achieving a
red color on TopCoder.
TopCoder, by the way, is another
programming contest.
They're the company that Google
went to in 2003 to run
the first Code Jam before Igor
and I and our cohorts took it
over for Google in 2008.
I would say that hard work
is huge in this.
I was recently having a
conversation with Petr
Mitrichev, who is possibly the
best competitor in the world
at programming contests.
And I asked him--
I needed a list of the
contests that he
participated in.
And I've participated in Code
Jam, ACM programming contest,
and TopCoder.
And those are essentially
the ones that I've
participated in.
He sent me 30 at least.
It may have been closer to 50.
So he is someone who is at the
top of the world because he
works very hard.
Now he's brilliant.
He's a very intelligent
person.
And there's no question that
that plays a role.
But he's passionate about it,
and he works extremely hard.
And that's why he's such
a good contestant.
I'm sure that you can find
examples in both directions
for people who maybe don't
consider themselves to be
brilliant, but are very hard
workers and have reached the
upper echelons.
And then you get people who are
14, and they're among the
best in the world.
There's a Belarusian,
I think, Gennady--
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Korotkevich.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: Thank you.
Who, at the age of 14, was
winning programming contests.
Global programming contests.
So there's definitely
something to be
said from both sides.
But I think that if you are the
kind of person who finds
this interesting, you are almost
certainly smart enough
with enough hard work to
hit the upper ends.
Because even the people at the
upper ends don't do this--
and it's not their job.
Right?
They do this as a hobby.
They do this in the evenings.
And so if you were really
passionate about it, you could
spend your evenings on it,
too, and you'd get there.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Yeah.
I'd say it's like
anything else.
Some people are naturally
greater or have some skills
that make them naturally good.
Some people work really hard
and get better at it.
The people who are the best,
they're usually some kind of
combination of both.
They have some natural
skill, and they work
really hard at it.
That's how they become the
best in the world.
Yeah.
I guess we can move on
to the next one.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: All right.
So the next one.
We've kind of answered the first
part of the question,
which is does competitive
programming help you in your
every day job?
And how so?
I talked a little bit about
how it increases your
vocabulary of things that
you have an easier time
writing code for.
And so it's more natural to do
more complicated tasks because
the building blocks
are bigger.
The next part of the question
is, do you imagine yourself in
your current position, role, or
company without ever having
participated in this kind
of competition?
Igor, do you want to
start on this one?
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Probably not.
So I got my first internship at
Google after competing in
Code Jam and getting
to the finals.
And that's how I got to Google
in the first place.
In general, I think I would
have a hard time passing
interviews without having
done lots of programming
competitions.
When I was interviewing at
Google, pretty much every
question they asked me that I
had to write code for, I've
seen before.
And I told them that.
It's like, all right.
Yeah, I've seen that.
Here's how you write the code.
And they asked me the
next question.
It's like, oh yeah.
I've seen that before
in contests.
Here's how you write the code.
And then the interviewers
ran out of questions.
[LAUGHTER]
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW:
That's good.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: That's
what you want to have.
Maybe there was some other way
I could have ended up here.
But I don't really see it.
It certainly was a lot easier
having had that experience.
Maybe "easier" is not the word
because I spent a lot of time
in programming competitions,
solving thousands of problems
on websites that was fun.
But it also had this
wonderful benefit.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: Yeah,
and I think--
Shoot.
I was going to say something
about what you just said.
But I've forgotten.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Well, your
story is similar to that.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: Yeah, I'll
talk about my own experience.
So as I mentioned before, I
have degrees in physics.
I took a couple of courses
in computer science
when I was an undergrad.
And I thought, oh this
is really neat.
I kind of like writing programs,
if only there were
actually something
I wanted to do.
If only there were a problem
that I wanted to solve.
And then I discovered these
programming competitions.
And then all a sudden there
were thousands of problems
that I wanted to solve.
Just look one up, write out the
code for it, and solve it.
So to me, that's very enticing
and exciting.
And that's what really got me
past the stage of just being a
little bit interested in
computer science, and to the
point where I was seriously
considering it as a career.
Oh, I've remembered what I
wanted to say about your
point, Igor.
By no means is competitive
programming the only way to
get good at Google interviews.
If you're the kind of person
who works on a lot of open
source projects, or you're a
professional coder, then
chances are you've done
quite a lot of coding.
You've done quite a lot of
thinking about some of the
kinds of problems that Google
interviewers are
likely to ask you.
On the other hand, I think for
interviews, in particular, I
think competitive programming
is particularly good.
But for day-to-day work, there's
a big old layer on top
of that that makes it more than
exclusively what we do in
programming contests.
So I mentioned that programming
contests are how I
got involved in computer
science.
But it actually goes a little
bit deeper than that.
So in 2003, I competed in
the first Code Jam.
And I wasn't actually
good enough to
make it to the finals.
But I got lucky.
So I made my way into
the finals by a
little bit of a fluke.
And one of the things I've
discovered is that I really
loved hanging out with
the people who
do programming contests.
There's some really interesting
people.
And coming from a physics
background, I love those
people, too.
But these competitive
programmers, they love board
games and card games.
They love logic puzzles.
They love thinking
about algorithms.
It was just I finally
found my people.
And then I thought, well maybe
Google would be a nice place
to work if there are people
like that around here.
And so that's how I ended up
applying for an internship.
And then after that, I did
another internship.
And then after that, I
came here full time.
But in addition to that, I can
also credit Code Jam and--
well not just Code Jam, but
other programming contests--
for a lot more than that because
in 2004, I went to the
finals of the ACM International
Collegiate
Programming Contest in Prague.
And I met the other Canadian
competitors there.
Igor was actually one.
And Igor would be my team
mate in the next year.
But I also met a competitor
from the University of
Calgary, whom I would later
end up marrying.
So this competitive programming
has had a really
big impact on my life.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: So which
question are we on?
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW:
Zack Baker here.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Are there any
online courses for competitive
programming?
And have you considered
creating or
contributing to a new one?
I don't know of any online
courses, per se.
But there are a few things
that you can do online.
There are actually lots of
things you can do online to
get better at programming
competitions.
You could look at
past contests.
Lots of them are online.
You can try to solve problems
from past contests.
There are plenty of blogs and
different websites devoted to
ranking problems by difficulty
and making--
I'm sure you can find problems
that you're interested in.
If you are really interested in
graph algorithms, I would
say one way to get better at it
is to read a book on graph
algorithms.
Another way is to solve a bunch
of graph problems in
programming competitions.
And there are websites, that'll
let you find those.
When I was an undergrad at
University of British
Columbia, I actually taught
a course on programming
competitions because there's so
many interesting problems
that you see there and so many
different algorithmic
techniques that you can use to
solve problems, that you don't
really learn about in
algorithms courses.
For example, there are a bunch
of ways to solve problems
using brute force that
are smarter than
just dumb brute force.
And sometimes, actually, in
real life, you run into
problems that are NP-Hard.
And if you just have a
theoretical background about
NP-Hard problems, you can sort
of say, well, we can give up.
Or we can try to find some
approximation maybe.
But yeah, this is
a hard problem.
Nobody knows how to solve it.
Another way to do that is to
say, well, what is the best
known algorithm?
Or what are some tricks that we
can use to actually go and
solve this problem that
everybody thinks is
impossible to solve?
And there are a bunch of these
tricks that you learn about in
programming competitions.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: Not that
they make a polynomial mind.
But you can often cut n in
half effectively for the
purposes of solving
the problem.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: So yeah.
There are plenty of
online courses.
Just look.
TopCoder.com is a great
place to start.
The Code Jam website is actually
not a bad place to
start either.
We have lots of rounds
that we post online.
Past rounds, including
all the problems.
And you can even download
solutions of anybody who's
solved this problem before.
If you start with the early
rounds of the tournament,
you'll see easier problems.
If you move to the finals, you
see really hard problems.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW:
That's right.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Find
your place.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: And because
we haven't plugged the
website yet,
code.google.com/codejam.
So if you go to the Code Jam
website, you'll also see that
we have registration open for
Code Jam 2013, which is the
contest where the finals
are in London.
And this is, I think, a really
great opportunity for people
to just try this out in a
competitive environment.
And it really gives you an
opportunity to see how great
some people are at it and
to measure your own
skill at it, as well.
And as we've mentioned for the
earlier contest, it only gets
better with time and
with practice.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK:
Next question.
What was the first coding
competition you
participated in?
What language did you use?
And what point did you know
you'd be addicted to coding
competitions?
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: Oh, you
know us so well, erbedont.
I first participated in an
internal contest at Queens
University, and then moved from
there to the ACM-ICPC,
then to Code Jam, then
to TopCoder.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Yeah my
story's very similar.
ACM was the first programming
competition because I found
out about competitions
in university.
And that's the biggest
university
competition out there.
A few of the top people that
I know found out earlier.
So there are high school
programming
competitions, as well.
I was nowhere near good enough
in high school in programming
to be able to compete in
any kind of level.
So yeah, I guess it's a similar
story to yours.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: Now at what
point did you know you'd
be addicted to coding
competitions?
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: I'm not sure
I'm addicted to programming
competitions.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: You can
stop any time you want.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Exactly.
I can stop any time I want.
That's right.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW:
I don't know.
I would say I really
got hooked when--
after I'd done a couple of
rounds, and I thought, oh wow.
This is good stuff.
And I really started
buckling down.
Now, Igor who says that he's
not addicted has solved
literally thousands of
problems online.
But there's a website that posts
hundreds of problems.
And Igor's well over
the 1,000 mark.
So don't taken him too seriously
when he says he's
not an addict.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: I'd say you
get addicted to things in a
good way at least.
It's a good thing to
get addicted to.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW:
A good thing, yes.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Either when you
get good at it, or you can
see yourself improving, that's
really addictive.
Or when you can find
somebody to compete
with, that was my example.
So one of my friends at school
was trying to solve more
problems than me.
And we were head-to-head.
And we spent the whole summer
trying to race each other on
the scoreboard of
that website.
And then that continued for a
couple of years and got way
out of hand.
So since then, we
both stopped.
And then he was just a few
places ahead of me.
And then six months later, I
went in and solved a few
problems to get ahead of him.
He still doesn't know.
VAN RIPER: So what happened
to that friend of yours?
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: He works at
a hedge fund in New York,
solving interesting programming
problems in that world.
I haven't seen him compete in
competitions in a while.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: But actually
a lot of our friends
from university have ended up
at Google, particularly the
University of British
Columbia crowd.
Igor and I were on the
same team one year.
Our teammate is at Google.
Lots of the people from
subsequent year's teams have
also been here.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Yeah, Google's
been pretty good at
hiring a lot of the top talent
from programming competitions.
There's a country ranking on
TopCoder where you can see
which country is doing better
than another country by
averaging in a smart way the
competitors from that country.
And somebody built kind of a
country ranking for Google, if
Google were a country.
And it's way above any other
country on TopCoder.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: I
think we're pretty
close to Russia, actually.
I think Russia's in the lead.
And where we're pretty close.
No?
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Last time I
checked, there were like--
it's not even comparable.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: OK.
Fair enough.
The best competitive
programmer at
Google is also Russian.
So maybe that says something
about us as a group.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: So what's
the next one?
How can programming competitions
learn from
example of marathon running
where events provide both a
highly competitive race for
elites, yet also a broader
audience and environment
for personal challenge?
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: Well, I
think that the earlier rounds
really are an environment
for personal challenge.
Like our qualification round is
effectively time unlimited.
It's a 25 hour round.
So you can essentially go
in anytime you want.
If it takes you three hours to
solve the easiest problem,
then that's fine.
And so that's an opportunity
for personal challenge.
But also contests like TopCoder
have had their
Division Two, which is for
newer competitors.
Some slightly easier problems.
And for students, anyway,
they can go to their--
likely, most students
have a school with
a programming team--
ACM programming team--
and there would probably be some
people with similar skill
level to measure themselves
against.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Yeah, I think
we definitely have both of
these qualities.
There is a really competitive
race at the top for the top
spots in any worldwide
competition.
And there's also a ton of people
who just do this in
their free time without even
participating in competitions.
There are these websites with
thousands of problems in them.
You can go and solve as many
problems as you want
in your free time.
And there are some people who
are hard core competitors.
They compete in any competition
that's out there.
They try to get the top spot.
And there are some people who
have solved thousands of
problems and have never really
competed in real time
competitions.
But they are at the
top of every
scoreboard on these websites.
So there are two kinds of
people that I know of.
And sometimes it's
the same person.
But sometimes there are groups
of people who never compete in
real time because it's a lot of
time pressure and stress.
But you can take your time and
spend a few hours on the
problem in the evening, and do
this for years and years.
And people who enjoy
doing that do that.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: And if you
go to the Code Jam website,
that's code.google.com/codejam,
then
what you'll find is that if you
look at the qualification
round-- that's the first round
of the contest in 2012--
there were around 20,000 people
who participated.
Now there aren't 20,000 people
in the world who
are great at this.
And there are a lot of people
who, for them, that was their
first programming contest.
And some of the people for
whom it was their first
programming contest struggled.
And some of them found that
actually they were
quite good at it.
And given that we're speaking to
an audience of developers,
I hope, then I think we'll find
that a lot of you are
actually in the second
category, off
to a very good start.
The next question is that
E-O-N-O-E asks if we have any
regular contests, like TopCoder
single round matches,
that people can use to
prepare for Code Jam.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: So we don't run
that many rounds or that
many contests during the year.
There are some websites, like
TopCoder, like Codeforces and
CodeChef and all these other--
there are more of those every
day, I think, or at least
every year.
There's no shortage of
competition to practice on.
You can also just spend free
time solving problems, trying
to rerun past competitions,
and see how you would have
done by imposing a time
limit on yourself.
You can go to, for example,
a Code Jam contest.
You know how long it was.
You can set aside
that much time.
You could try to solve the
problems by not looking at
them beforehand.
And you see where you would
have ended up on the
scoreboard.
Our scoring and penalty
algorithms are pretty simple
so you can easily figure out
where you would have ended up.
So that you can do that way.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: But to be
honest, the sorts of skills
that you build by solving Code
Jam problems and the sorts of
skills that you need to solve
Code Jam problems are pretty
similar to the sorts of skills
that you need to solve
TopCoder problems, or the sorts
of skills you build by
solving TopCoder problems.
So go do TopCoder rounds.
That would be a great way of
preparing for Code Jam.
That would be fantastic.
For those of you who are
watching us live, I'd like to
remind you that we have
a Moderator page
with a bunch of questions.
And it's short enough right now
that if you were to post
some more questions of your own,
then chances are pretty
good that we'll get to them.
So if you've got any questions
for Igor Naverniouk or for me,
then please log on and go
ahead and ask them.
The next question asks, what do
you think if the Code Jam
format were changed to something
like the ACM-ICPC?
For example, in the ACM-ICPC,
there are these regional
contests where different
schools compete
against each other.
He's proposing super
regional Code Jams.
And then the people from the
regionals would qualify for
finals and go to the
onsite finals.
We actually did that in 2008.
The sort of big year that we
first reintroduced Code Jam.
And that was a lot of fun.
We haven't done it
again recently.
But it's definitely not out
of the question that
we could do it again.
I don't know if it did.
The end of the question was,
could that encourage more
people to participate?
I'm not sure if it encouraged
more people to participate.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Not enough to
justify the amount of effort
that went into running these
lots of regional competitions.
That was hard to do.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: That
was really hard to do.
But it was fun.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: It
means having to
create a lot more problems.
And that was where most
of our time was spent.
It's also not easy to organize
that many different sites.
And trying to do it at the
same time is challenging
across different time zones.
So there's a price to
pay for doing this.
We did get a bump
in registration.
We definitely had way
more registrants
than the year before.
We can think about doing
this again maybe.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: Yeah.
We won't rule it out
for the future.
Maybe sometime.
VAN RIPER: Can I interject
a personal question?
You talked about
more problems.
I mean how do you guys come up
with the problems, when given
it's been going for
10 years now.
Coming up with new problems
must be a challenge.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: That
is a challenge.
We're blessed here at Google
with a very large number of
programming contest competitors
who are just really--
they have a lot of experience,
and they have great
imaginations.
And so what we end up having
is essentially this big
brainstorming thing, where we've
got an internal website,
and people post their
ideas to it.
And some of the ideas are fully
fledged programming
problems, and others are the
sort of thing that you need to
think about a little more.
I pretty regularly have lunch
with David Arthur, who's
another programming contestant
and problem setter.
And we'll just talk through
a problem that's sort of a
half-formed idea in
one of our heads.
And eventually it'll end up on
Code Jam a lot of the time.
So look for one of those on
the finals this year.
I think it's problem
B. I'm not sure.
But for me, when I'm coming up
with problems, I kind of, in
my day-to-day life, I'll
come across something.
There's a problem, I think, from
2011 called "Candy Store"
that asks about a guy needing to
stock up his store in order
to sell candy.
And I actually came across
this when I was trying to
figure out if I wanted
to be able to lift
weights with two hands.
I wanted to be able to select
any amount of weight up to 12
pounds in both hands, then
what weights would
I need to do it?
So you could do two one-pound
weights, two two-pound
weights, two four-pound
weights,
two eight-pound weights.
But that's actually not
the most efficient
thing you could do.
You can do instead one two-pound
weight and a
three-pound weight, or
something like that.
I can't do the gritty algorithm
in my head.
But for me, I come across the
situations in day to day life,
and then I write problems
about them.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Yeah, I've
written quite a few problems.
And I'd say they fall into
one of two categories.
How do you describe where
inspiration comes from?
Nobody knows.
Some of those are kind of
similar to what Bartholomew
was describing.
You run into a situation in
regular life where you say,
well, this could be done better,
or I wonder if I can
turn this into sort of a more
well-defined problem.
And you come up with a little
story around it.
And hopefully there's some
interesting algorithm
that can solve it.
That actually happens
pretty frequently.
Another way, especially back
when I was at university,
reading a bunch of papers for
research, you run into some
algorithm in the paper, and
you say, well, that's an
interesting and obscure
algorithm.
How do I make that useful?
How do I actually turn it into a
story where you can use this
algorithm to solve some
interesting problem?
And that's an interesting
exercise to do
in science, in general.
But yeah.
How does a writer come up with
an idea for a short story?
Who knows?
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: Yeah,
from anywhere.
So Igor described-- there are
essentially two approaches.
One is to have a situation
and then come up with
algorithm to solve it.
And the other is you have
an algorithm and go
looking for a situation.
And different people approach
it in different ways.
VAN RIPER: Great.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: OK.
So the next question here is--
I think these have
changed in order.
What do you think is of higher
importance, practicing or
reading books on algorithms?
How can you practice unless
you know it's the
right way to do it?
I think that's a really great
question, actually.
For me, I like to have the
motivation to solve a problem
before learning the method
to solve it.
To read an algorithm in
a book is one thing.
But then if I don't have a
problem that I want to solve,
it's not quite as interesting
to me.
Contests like Code Jam and
TopCoder, after the matches
are over, will typically
write an editorial.
So if you go to the Code Jam
website and you come across
this problem and you have no
idea how to solve it, and you
think about it for a while and
decide, you know what, I just
don't know how to do this, you
can go to the Contest Analysis
page, which is just a link
on the same page
as the problem was.
And you just read
how to do it.
And we try to write out
a clear explanation.
And if you can't understand our
super clear explanation
because occasionally they're not
entirely clear, you could
go to our Google+ community
and ask for help.
Or go to our mailing list
And people are happy to help you
out as long as you mention
the problem name, which
some people forget to.
And so for me, I really love
the approach of find the
problem first, and then find
out how to solve it.
But different people learn
in different ways.
And I can totally
imagine that--
supposing you read about dynamic
programming in a book,
then you could search
the web for
dynamic programming problems.
And I don't think we have
categorizations like
that for Code Jam.
There's no list of dynamic
programming
problems for Code Jam.
But maybe we should make that.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Somebody
could make that
if they want to.
[LAUGHTER]
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: Somebody
else should make that.
We're busy.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: I get lots
of email, actually, from
contestants around the world,
asking me the same question
over and over again.
So how do I get better?
And they actually ask
this as a question.
Do I read more books, or do I
practice more problem solving?
And my answer is usually do
what's more fun because if
it's not fun, you're not
going to be doing it.
If you like solving problems, if
you like this gratification
of actually submitting
a solution
and saying it's correct--
seeing the correct response
come back--
then do more of that.
If you like learning more
algorithms from books, read
more books.
It's unlikely that you're going
to reach some limit on
the book reading where you're
not going to get any better by
reading more books.
And it's also unlikely that
you're going to reach some
limit of problem solving where
just solving more problems is
not going to get you better.
So do whatever is more fun.
And better yet, find a friend
who also likes doing this, and
do it together.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: Yeah.
Solid advice.
And for people who are looking
for resources on learning
these things, if you
go to our website,
code.google.com/codejam, there's
a link that says
Practice and Learn.
And on that link, you click that
and you get a whole page
full of resources.
We've got a list of the easiest
Code Jam problems to
get started with.
And we've also got a list
of all the old Code Jam
competitions.
And we also list other websites
that you can go to,
like TopCoder, like the Sphere
Online Judge, and other
opportunities for you to solve
problems and learn.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: What about some
team challenges for one
of the coming Code Jams where
universities could win Google
Developer boot camps or
something like that?
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW:
There's an idea.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: We thought
about that.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: We've
thought about team contests
before, haven't we?
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Yep.
It may happen.
Not this year.
We're still deciding the
best way to do that.
Team competitions have an
interesting dynamic to them.
ACM-ICPC is the most
well known team
competition out there.
So Bartholomew and I were
in the same team
competing in that.
You get to run into some
interesting challenges there.
For example, you only get one
computer for three people.
So you have to optimize--
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: That's
in ACM, though.
It probably wouldn't be
the case for Code Jam.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Sure.
But I'm just saying that they
come with different
challenges, which are
also interesting.
It would be really difficult to
mix team competitions with
individual ones.
So we would have to come up
with something separate.
So I've been thinking about it
for a few years, but I haven't
come up with any concrete
idea that we could do it
differently.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: In some
ways, team competitions are
fundamentally unfair because
if you know somebody who's
good, then you'll have a better
team than somebody who
only knows bad people.
Not be pejorative.
But someone who only knows
people who aren't as
skilled, and so--
we're a little less enthusiastic
about it for that
reason, as well, because you
kind of want everyone to be on
equal footing to some extent.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: I don't know.
I've seen the situation
in ACM where you have
three excellent people.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: Who
can't work together.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: I've been
coaching the team for a while.
So I coached for a few years
at University of British
Columbia in Toronto.
And we run an internal
competition to figure out who
are the best individual
programmers.
And then it's my job to put
together some teams for the
regional competition.
And sometimes you run into a
situation where you take the
three best individual coders,
and you put them together on
the team and it's disaster.
They can't work together.
They start fighting
over things.
So there's some interesting
questions there, too.
So just because you know the
best people doesn't mean you
can make the best team, like
in any other sport.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: That's
a good point.
Though to be fair, ACM requires
particular team
challenges of sharing one
computer, whereas if we did
Code Jam, maybe you don't really
need-- you just divvy
up the problems and then
go do your own thing.
So we lose some of the dynamic
there, which is also--
but we're thinking about it.
All right let's see.
Is there anything
else on here?
Boy, these keep jumping
around.
So what about some team
challenges, he asked again.
Does the winner of Code Jam get
a job offer at Google, as
the registration page asks which
Google office you want
to work for?
No.
We definitely consider excellent
performance on Code
Jam, or any other programming
contest, when we're thinking
about who to hire.
But we also ask when you
register for Code Jam, are you
interested in a job at Google?
And if so, what office would
you want to work at?
And then if the answer is yes,
then we might contact you
whether you do well, or not.
But it's definitely not a prize
for the contest to get a
job at Google.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Yeah, we have
done some things in the past
to make this easier
for people.
So one, you can sign up if
you're interested in a job.
We'll send you an email,
especially if you do well.
Another is typically to get a
job at Google, you go through
two stages of interviews.
There are phone screens and
there are onsite interviews.
And for finalists, in the past
couple of years, we've let
them essentially skip
phone screens.
So we may consider
doing that again.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: And it's on
a person by person basis.
They didn't get that because
they were a finalist.
They got that because
they're good.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: But generally,
I would say if you
really want to get a job at
Google, and you want to use
programming competitions to get
that, it's not that this
is going to be a prize for
winning the competition.
It's just that from getting
better at competitions, you're
going to get so much better at
interviews that you'll get the
job anyway.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: And
not just interviews.
But also at writing code.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Well at
writing code, too.
Yeah, so hopefully there's
some correlation between
interviews--
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW:
We hope so.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: --and
job performance.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: All right.
This is kind of an inside
baseball question.
So apologies to people who
aren't Code Jam aficionados.
Last year in the qualification
round, we had one easy problem
for 15 points, and you needed
20 points to qualify.
Do we have the same type of
thing going on this year?
We're not going to tell you.
So what this person is asking
about is in the qualification
round, because it's not really
timed-- you've got 25 hours
and you can compete whenever--
you just need a certain number
of points to advance to the
next round.
And so in previous years, we
typically made it so that
fully solving one problem
is enough.
Last year, we made it so there
was one problem that if you
fully solved it, you didn't
get onto the next round.
We might do that this year.
We might not.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: I think this
one's slightly similar to a
previous question.
What's the motivation behind
the problems in Code Jam?
Does Code Jam ever pose
problems Google
engineers work on?
I know I've done it
a couple times.
I run into some algorithmic
challenges in
my day-to-day work.
And I've sort of isolated the
interesting part of that
problem, wrote some story around
it, and made it into a
programing contest problem.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: Though to
be clear, unfortunately we
can't make you do our work for
us because we have to be able
to tell if you solved
it right.
So we have to solve it correctly
ourselves first.
As much as I would like to have
30,000 people doing my
job for me, it doesn't
work like that sadly.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: There are some
kinds of problems we get
to solve at work that we can't
ask in a programming
competition just because
of the kinds of tools
we get to play with.
It's hard to write a programming
problem where we
say, well what if you
had 1,000 computers?
How can you solve it then?
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: 1,000
computers and the MapReduce
architecture.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Yeah.
So we get to do that at work.
We can't really turn that
into a programming
contest problem yet.
Although we can think
about that.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: We
can think about that.
But I guess that's--
to throw in a brief plug for
working at Google-- that's one
of the ways in which working
at Google is different from
programming contests, is that
you get cooler toys to play
with in a way.
You can throw a lot of computers
at a problem.
And there are a lot of really
interesting algorithmic
questions that come up when
you've got 1,000 computers
instead of one.
All right.
Our next question here comes
from JPJ in Atlanta, Georgia.
What is your favorite language
to use in competitions?
Which language would you
recommend people to
use for Code Jam?
Igor?
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: My favorite
programming language to use in
competitions is C++ because
it's I know it best.
I know it better than most
other languages.
And it's short to write.
And it has all the
tools that I need
for programming contests.
That's my personal view.
There are lots of people who
use all sorts of other
programming languages.
Although it depends
on the problem.
There are some problems where
you need the integer
arithmetic, which is kind
of painful in C++.
So you may want to use Python.
There are some problems where
you may want to create a bunch
of threads because that's
going to simplify some
computation.
Maybe Java's the way to go.
Or Go or something.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW:
Or Go, yeah.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: Choose the
right tool for the job.
And learn one, at least,
really well.
And probably a few.
That's better.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: When I
started competing, I competed
in Java because that's the
only language I knew.
But then I learned C++ and I
started using that because it
was a little more succinct.
And then after that--
actually to work on Code Jam,
because the Code Jam platform
is written in Python,
I learned Python.
And there are certain problems
I'd rather solve in Python
than in C++.
So when I compete, I use
either Python or
C++ to solve problems.
Let's see.
Here at my university, people
don't get very interested in
competitive programming because
they usually get
frustrated when they fail to
solve problems, which is very
common for everyone
at the start.
How can I change that?
Well, [INAUDIBLE], I don't know
if you're a coach or a
student, or what.
But typically, the best way to
get people not frustrated by
problems that they can't solve
is to give them easy problems.
That's how you get
people into it.
You give them problems
that they can solve.
And so if you're running
contests, then come up with
simple problems to solve them.
If you look at our qualification
rounds for Code
Jam, that's the round when
anybody in the world can get
into this round and start trying
to solve problems.
We want it so that anyone
who tries to
participate can solve something.
And so our first problem
will typically be
something that's fairly--
not too algorithmically
complex and
not too hard to implement.
So those are the two dimensions
that you have to be
careful about, algorithmic
complexity, and difficulty to
figure out the solution,
and difficulty to
implement the solution.
So you might consider coming
up with problems
that are easy in both.
Or maybe you are just so much
better at one than the other
that it's harder to see.
But run your problems by friends
who are actually into
competitive programming, and see
just how easy you can make
the first couple of questions
on your contest.
And hook them in that way.
IGOR NAVERNIOUK: There are lots
of signals you can use to
figure out how hard a problem
is before you
start solving it.
For example, in Code Jam, we
give point values to problems.
So easier problems usually
get fewer points.
Harder ones get more points, to
the best of our knowledge.
Sometimes we mess that up.
We also have several
parts to a problem.
Usually there's one
problem statement.
But there are several different
input files with
different limits on them.
So you can solve the small
ones, which is easier.
Maybe you have lots
of different
algorithms you can use there.
And there's a hard one
that requires a
more complicated algorithm.
So start with the easy ones,
and find that line.
Solve easy problems, and get to
harder problems until you
cant solve them anymore.
And then figure out how
to solve those.
TopCoder does it differently.
TopCoder has two divisions.
You have Division One
and Division Two.
You start in Division Two.
And when you get good enough to
start winning in Division
Two, you get moved up
to Division One.
So different competitions
do it differently.
If you're trying to figure it
out during a competition if
you're in a live round, see what
other people have solved.
Or on some website where you're
getting these problems,
see how many other people have
solved the problems.
And start with the ones that
have lots of solutions.
Don't just randomly
pick a problem.
That's very frustrating.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW:
Very frustrating.
I think we're about to
run out of time here.
VAN RIPER: Yeah.
That might actually be a good
segue for me to just mention I
want to encourage everyone to
consider participating in
Google Code Jam 2013.
First round starts April 12.
I also want to say that,
independent of Code Jam, I
think especially for our
chapters, this is the Google
Developer Group session here.
Especially for you organizers
out there with smaller
chapters, I think taking
programming problems and
letting everyone in the group
go off and work at them, and
then come back and have someone
that had a good
solution share it and discuss
it would be a great way for
some of the smaller groups to
do some programming activity
as a group.
And so I want to encourage you,
whether you get involved
in Code Jam or not, which I do
encourage you to do, think
about incorporating this in
your activities as a local
developer group.
Because the reason I got into
this is I liked hanging out
with other programmers
and solving problems.
So that's why I loved having
you guys on today.
So I really appreciate
your time.
And I hope some of our audience
are inspired to go
forward and join
Code Jam 2013.
BARTHOLOMEW FURROW: Thanks
very much, Van.
[MUSIC PLAYING]